what up reject nation today we are gonna check
out the stranger things four trailer but before
we jump into that big thank you to today's
video sponsor creeps unfortunately two out
of three guys will experience some form of hair
loss by the age of 35 which means in a few years
john's good looks will be gone luckily keeps is
here to help you improve growth and even stop
hair loss with their clinically proven treatments
they'll put you in touch with their expert team of
medical advisors and specialists to devise the
perfect care regimen delivered straight to your
door so you don't miss a beat each treatment
comes with a full year of unlimited messaging
with your prescribing doctor so you can keep them
posted ask questions in real time even if you're
still to take better care of your hair it keeps it
hard hair loss stops with keeps and to get 50 off
your first order go to keeps.com real rejects or
click the link in the description that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash real rejects thanks again for
sponsoring this video now let's swing into this
you've broken everything
was that robert england probably it's his house
billy so sexy dear billy i don't
know if you can even hear this
oh he can upside down ever since he
left everything's been a total disaster
for a while we tried to be happy normal there's
no normal for you guys it's impossible cool
house with a clock and it's walls
i relocated you guys far from hawkins
because i thought he'd be safe
stamps are the new clue is that
a package from russia with love
it's coming i'm afraid your friends at
hawkins are very much it's paul ryzer's voice
i don't have my powers i don't know how
to say this other than just to say it
we need you without you we can't win this war
hello
oh damn demobats
on the other side
what the hell going on there like a demogorgon
prison fight people say hawkins is close whoa whoa
what the hell robert england yes
holy [ __ ] like some resident
evil [ __ ] you have lost
wow is that who robert england's play i mean
there's at least one image of him as like
a regular guy with his eyes gouged out but it
almost seems like maybe there is like an upside
down equivalent of him or something i mean you've
got to keep up with the annie from demogorgon to
mind flare to now whatever hellraiser guy i mean
they did say they're going more overtly horror
this season so i mean i wouldn't be surprised and
to cast an icon of horror like robert england and
i mean you know it's only the first time i've
seen that image but there's a little bit of you
know a freddy reminiscence in that face there at
least i'm not sure what to make of that the way
how the last trailer made it look with the creel
house he is a victim of a circumstance where he
was framed for a murder that wasn't actually his
responsibility but probably perhaps some creature
from the upside down that murdered his family
the things that you see with these creatures
especially in like season three is often the
hybrids of like upside down entity and human
hybrid and then maybe the key to them obtaining
ultimate power is the perfect hybrid and maybe
that's what he is i have no idea i i really have
no clue but this looks like the most expansive out
of any season like you are like out of hawkins for
so much of this you're in california russia and so
much of the upside down and it looks so horrific
and there were like little glimpses that we got
throughout i re finished my re-watch of stranger
things like like a couple weeks ago i want to say
well it has me curious of what thematically
what this season is going to be because the
first season was so much about like trauma being
inflicted and fears and anxieties and such growing
as a person based off of those and the second
season dealt so much with ptsd and the third
season was all about moving forward or learning
to move forward here this season seems to be about
in that path of moving forward when your past
catches up with you how do you deal with that
you know which is such a part of life so i feel
like the first three seasons thematically are
perfectly complemented yeah it starts off at the
very top with we're trying to have a normal life
you see that lucas is on the basketball team
and then levin is going to school i wonder
if she has a different name other than 11 and
she's trying to be normal and her hair looks
exactly like joyce's or something he's not going
by jane now is she maybe yeah that's right about
it make more sense she's probably like learning
to accept her past actually you know what that
guy that might be billy oh yeah hey that's also
a good call yeah yeah yeah cause it definitely i
mean like the upside down infects everybody but
it seems like it especially took over billy's
mind and body although i don't know maybe because
i feel like sometimes stranger things they try to
mislead you with their marketing right he had
certain images here where like max at one point
were at the same scene at the cemetery it seems
that they're going to comfort her but then her
herself starts to levitate i'm not sure if these
scenes with 11 are purely flashbacks to uncover
things because so much of her was about escaping
her past and not wanting to relive and it's such a
triggering event for her to be reminded of things
like the rainbow room and such wonder if they
if it is like present day and then bring her
and then bring her back to it because you know
there's a lot of theories that dr bretter will
be back this season not just in the form of
flashbacks because we didn't actually see him
die in the first season if it's an off-camera
death it doesn't count they are still alive he got
attacked by demogorgon but we didn't see his body
so he might still be alive still on the table
and then of course like with hopper and russia
it seems that he might bond with some of the
prisoners actually in like an attempt to it seems
like they're going to escape at one point and then
they have to take out the demigorgon themselves at
least it would look like at that one scene either
that or they're doing like some kind of twisted
like gladiator fights with like the prisoners
and demogorgons or something but either way it
looks like hopper might be instrumental in i don't
know yeah helping to save some of those guys or at
least you know being the one to show everybody
that they don't know what they're dealing with
what they have on their hands here well this
is also going to probably deal with time travel
if i'm not mistaken or maybe not time travel but
some type of dimensional because i don't feel like
you know you do see murray and joyce at one
point in a plane and it looks like they're
probably trying to rescue hopper you know you got
those clues in there from the stamps there's maybe
there are these clues like she's receiving
from hopper that maybe he's still alive so i
they're probably trying to go rescue
him or he finds some type of gateway
that he gets him back to hawkins or something
maybe there's some kind of rabbit hole within
the upside down that connects places where they
shouldn't connect or something like that and
it's also going to probably be like it looks like
heavy metal i was just guessing it's going to be
tone and beam of this yeah heavy metal aesthetics
of like everybody getting a little older and
discovering rebellious music and i don't know
how that bit on top of the bus with the electric
guitar in the upside down is gonna play out that
looks like one of the more broad things and i
feel like the seasons get broader as they go and
that is something that while i'm wary in the sense
that i don't want to get too cartoony and i feel
like you could argue that season three does broach
that i am i'm very excited to see what heavy metal
does to all these kids and everybody around them
in hawkins in california wherever else i have
a strong feeling that paul reiser's probably
gonna die in this season just based off the way
this trade i imagine that maybe even volume one
his carrot that's when his character will die and
then of course with eleven maybe so much of this
is about her learning to ex truly come to terms
with her past because i don't feel like she ever
really has here with her losing her powers off
of the end of season three dealing with bullying
while being at a brand new school you know like
going from small town to california and dealing
with what the society is like over there and
then literally being pulled back into this whole
world and then with her they actually need her
whereas a poor look like she was you know someone
who was a prisoner even though she's they're
putting her into prison transport and stuff but
they're actually asking for her help and so she'll
need to like find her powers from within again and
maybe she'll come back even stronger than before
yeah i think that matches what you said about this
sort of idea that you can't and necessarily leave
your past behind and maybe for 11 it's going to be
a sort of arc where it's that she is connected
to this war as they're calling it now no matter
what these things that are breaking through the
upside down in this whole situation that has come
of ill-fated government experiments as unfair
and terrible as that is maybe yeah it's that
she is connected to it and if she can access
herself from a place of power maybe she is the
only key to stopping it or something like that
all right guys well stranger things season four
are you guys excited this looks like an epic ass
season they said it'd be the biggest and you could
tell it'll be the biggest what do you guys think
leave your thoughts down below subscribe click
that bell hit that like button thanks to keeps
for sponsoring this video last but not least
deontay w tongue punch fart box now when i think
of a demogorgon who do i think at our patreon
page most resembles what a demogorgon looks like
it's definitely a tongue punch fart box it has
that and yeah and that it just looks do i need to
really explain in depth what a tongue punch fart
box ought to look like or if there's any way you
could defeat a demogorgon it wouldn't be with some
steve harrington baseball bat or some 11
powers no the only thing that could take
down endemic organ is the equal and opposite
power which is a tongue punch fart so either way
you're most suited for this thanks thanks
for being here deante you're good man